Ми їдемо на російсько-грузинський кордон.
Існує підозра, що звідси попри санкції ЄС товари із західних країн переправляються в Росію.
З'ясуємо, чи це правда.
- Що змінилося за останні кілька місяців?
- Можу так сказати, нічого не змінилося. Як було, так і залишилося.
Ми в Грузії - країні, яка попри прагнення приєднатися до ЄС,
економічно тісно пов'язана з Росією.
Навіть на тлі війни.
Офіційно Грузія підтримує політику західних санкцій:
продукцію, яка може мати військове призначення,
заборонено експортувати до Росії. Включно з передовими технологіями,
безпілотниками та запчастинами для нафтової промисловості.
Але що відбувається насправді?
У місті Зугдіді нас зустрічає депутатка місцевого парламенту Даріко Арканія.
Вона веде нас на прикордонний контроль.
Поліція вже дивиться.
Цей правоохоронець схоже нервує.
Він хоче уточнити у свого начальника, чи дозволено нам тут знімати.
Тим часом: один невеликий фургон за іншим проїжджає шлагбаум.
Деяким людям доводиться зупинитися для перевірки.
Але цьому зеленому сміттєвозу проїзд дозволяють.
Він їздитиме туди-сюди кожні десять хвилин протягом наступної години.
Незрозуміло, що він везе.
Але впадає у вічі, що ті, хто мали би його перевіряти, відводять погляд.
Звичайних людей жорстко контролюють.
А коли контрабанда - закривають очі.
Пункт контролю тут особливий.
Грузинське місто Зугдіді лежить на лінії розмежування з абхазьким регіоном.
За міжнародним правом регіон належить Грузії, але де-факто
перебуває під контролем Росії.
Багато абхазців мають російське громадянство.
З точки зору санкцій це означає, що все, що потрапляє в Абхазію,
де-факто знаходиться в Росії.
Ось що робить цей пункт пропуску таким важливим.
Відтепер ми можемо знімати лише таємно. Офіцер хоче, щоб ми пішли.
Все це наша держава бачить і контролює. Але вона закриває на це очі.
Коли наші партнери зі США, Європи говорять, що в Грузії "чорна діра",
що росіяни тут можуть провозити свою контрабанду,
що всілякі товари можна везти до Росії, - це все правда.
Це підтверджує і норвезький економіст Ерленд Боллман Бьортведт,
який досліджував різні маршрути постачання санкційних товарів до Росії.
Вантажівка може стояти в Грузії, але де-факто вона на підконтрольній Росії території.
І це лише ОДИН із можливих варіантів обходу санкцій.
Про це свідчать торгівельна статистика, стверджує експерт.
У нас є дані торгівлі щодо Росії. Тож ми фактично бачимо, як товари надходять до Росії
з третіх країн. Ви можете побачити, які товари, скільки кілограмів
або одиниць товарів. Ми також знайшли деякі товари в Росії, наприклад,
дрони з камерою, які були експортовані із західних країн.
Їх теж виявили в Росії.
Цілком очевидно, що західні товари потрапляють до Росії попри санкції.
Ми їдемо до Тбілісі, щоб запитати про це грузинських урядовців.
Ми робимо все можливе, щоб контролювати всі товари, усі компанії та всіх осіб,
які перебувають у списку санкцій країн Великої сімки та інших країн, які запровадили санкції.
Але статистика свідчить про інше.
Приміром, на тлі скорочення поставок до Росії експорт
німецьких компаній до країн-сусідів РФ збільшується.
Грузія та інші сусідні з Росією країни не стали в одну мить настільки багатшими,
щоб пояснити таке збільшення імпорту.
Єдина вірогідна причина - частина цих товарів реекспортується в Росію.
Ці грузинські демонстранти виступають проти Росії.
Їхня конкретна вимога: Грузія повинна не допустити потрапляння до Росії
так званих товарів подвійного призначення.
Це товари, які можна використовувати як у цивільних,
так і у військових цілях, наприклад, мікрочипи.
Прем'єр-міністр не зміг відповісти на запитання: де є хоч один акт, закон,
підзаконний акт, наказ міністра, який регулює це питання і захищає Грузію
від ризику стати чорною дірою. Не можна керувати державою усними заявами.
Треба мати законодавчий акт.
Бо якщо немає відповідного законодавства, його й не можна порушити.
Це створює сіру зону, в якій торгівля санкційними продуктами
зрештою залишається безкарною.
Їдемо на околицю міста. Автомобілів західного виробництва тут
надзвичайно багато. Ми на одному з найбільших авторинків на Кавказі.
З початком війни росіяни більше не можуть купувати дорогі елітні автомобілі
безпосередньо на Заході. Ця санкція, з одного боку, спрямована
проти заможних росіян. З іншого боку, ще одна ціль такої заборони -
наскільки це можливо унеможливити використання західних автівок
для перевезення російських військових, наприклад, на фронт.
На полі бою дуже корисно мати потужний дизельний автомобіль, позашляховик.
Ми бачимо, що ці автомобілі використовуються як багатіями, так і в бойових цілях.
Наскільки легко придбати позашляховики на таких ринках, як цей?
На приховану камеру запитуємо у автодилера.
Тут великий ринок. Приїжджають казахи, киргизи, азербайджанці,
вірмени сюди приїжджають, щоб купити нормальну машину.
Можливо, вони купують і для Росії. Якщо це киргиз, то він купує машину,
привозить її в Киргизію і там перепродає. Вони перекупщики.
Тобто така схема, виходить, абсолютно легальна:
автомобіль може дістатися до Киргизії легально через Азербайджан і Каспійське море.
А там все дуже просто. Киргизія, як і інші країни регіону, в Митному союзі з Росією.
Продовжуємо озиратися. Майже ніхто не хоче з нами спілкуватися.
Поступово з розмов ми дізнаємося, що існує щонайменше ще декілька шляхів обійти санкції.
- Росія-Казахстан-Киргизія.
- Тобто звідси?
- Потягом. Автовозом, знаєте? Машини завантажують і їдуть.
Це офіційний транспортний маршрут. Але дилери припускають,
що як тільки автомобіль опиниться на території Росії, він може залишитися там.
Ми почули про ще один маршрут до Росії - через Вірменію.
До грузино-вірменського кордону дві години їзди. Знімати тут суворо заборонено.
Перед кордоном - вантажівка з автівками.
Але на камеру водії говорити відмовляються.
Після повернення до Тбілісі ми вирішили й самі спробувати
відправити в Росію елітний автомобіль.
Цей Mercedes продає іранський дилер. Авто в чудовому стані.
Невеликий пробіг. Шкіряний комплект.
Домовляємося про 55 тисяч доларів. Достатньо кількох дзвінків.
А чи є якийсь варіант, як нам у Москву відправити?
Від дилера дізнаємося - автомобіль можна експортувати в Росію
через Іран і Каспійське море. Ще одна лазівка.
Нам достатньо цієї інформації, тож покупку ми скасовуємо.
Стає дедалі очевидніше: у цьому регіоні багато санкцій Заходу
провалюються через реальність.
Останній тест: доїжджаємо до кордону Грузії з Росією.
Якщо і тут є шахрайство і контрабанда, то це підтвердить, що відсутність контролю
- проблема системна.
Велика кількість вантажівок, що очікують перетину кордону, викликає підозру.
Це не виглядає як обвал експорту в Росію. Навпаки!
Єдина надія на те, що з моменту запровадження санкцій Заходу
тут принаймні функціонує жорсткий моніторинг.
- У Грузії 2 хвилини - і можеш їхати на митницю.
- Можу так сказати, нічого не змінилося. Як було, так і залишилося.
- Нічого особливо не змінилося.
Якби Грузія та інші сусідні країни мали бажання технічно контролювати цю торгівлю,
то це було б можливо. Можна перевірити, що знаходиться всередині вантажівок.
Але я не очікую, що такі країни, як Грузія, Казахстан чи інші сусіди Росії,
реально контролюватимуть чи навіть обмежуватимуть торгівлю з РФ.
Під час нашої подорожі Грузією ми знайшли багато лазівок для обходу західних санкцій.
Нині ЄС готовий реагувати і обмежити деякі види експорту до третіх країн,
таких як Казахстан, Вірменія чи Грузія.